jk rowling debuted harry potter in 1997.
you have read those right uh no
i read uh
the hunger games
okay that's right same thing like a
teenager
flying through the
clouds you know
whatever
they're nonsense i yeah i was there
harry potter i don't think i've ever
even watched i'll watch them if like
harper wants to like which i'll go
through all that stuff all this stuff i
just don't care like yeah uh
so i was never just i was just never
into it they're remaking this is hbo hbo
series harry potter yeah
yeah i don't think i'll care house will
be awesome man but you loved it oh yeah
so yeah yeah but i didn't like the
movies at all so if they remake it
well
oh you did not like the movies no
because you liked the book so much yeah
well the the movies were not very good